hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem video und
dem titel eingeblendet wir machen heute
einen text wer mich besser kennen und
zwar max hallo du musst dich mal selber
film high max macht heute einen test
gegen apple selbst irgendwo aber nicht
da auf jeden fall werde ich das ganze
für euch so zusammenschneiden das ist so
aus als wenn erstmals die frage gestellt
bekommt und an konzepten die frage
gestellt und ich würde sagen ich glaube
da nicht mehr lange und wir fangen
direkt an wie viele paar schuhe
wie viele paar schuhe habe ich
schätzfrage schätzfrage wenn der andere
gewinnt in köln jetzt oder insgesamt
insgesamt 13 13 haben
bis hin zum sich aber mal schauen was
sind die im flur stehen alle die du hast
also ich kann so viel sagen die die im
flur stehen sie nicht alle die ich habe
ok
15 sonntag nicht geburtstag 21
februar 96 ist mich einfach mal 21
februar 96 okay das hat max auch gesagt
von daher geht der punkt an beide welche
sternzeichen bin ich dementsprechend vor
dass keiner fragt man nicht einhält dann
auch mein sternzeichen gewendet die
kennen keine sternzeichen kenne ich was
manche wassermann ein stil geschütze
schütze steinbock es ist fisch wie
vielen personen folge ich auf instagram
ich würde sagen um die 100 165 165 ok
alles klar war es ja mal voll viel
fanpage auch gefolgt wieder im volk dann
wieder gefolgt deshalb habe ich keine
ahnung wieviel trend sind 120 120 ps 156
nächste frage wie viele pflanzen habe
ich insgesamt in meiner wohnung also
künstliche und echte pflanzen 77
pflanzen natürlich kurz überlegen ich
mache jetzt echte und unechte zusammen
quasi
ok dann würde ich sagen 7 ist einfach
mal insgesamt vielleicht 20 als 90 ja
das ist richtig da welche schuhgröße
habe ich
[Musik]
44 42 45 echt was war der erste fifa
teil den ich je gespielt habe auf der
station oder pc auf jeden fall eine
frage die ich beantworten könnt also auf
konsole auf konsolen nicht nennen weil
ich heute das ist bei mir und so was in
fifa 09 war dann sagt jan fischer 84 08
damit habe ich aber auch sagen ich sage
einfach mal 06 richtig das habe ich aber
auch schon mal erzählt glaube ich komme
mir nun zuletzt eine frage man wie viele
videos habe ich bisher insgesamt auf
youtube hochgeladen 1.500 3.000 für mich
glaube ich sogar mal gesehen 2500 2500
sagst du die richtige antwort 2087
wahrscheinlich in das video hier raus
kommt ein bisschen mehr aber ich gerne
vor produziere
[Musik]
ich habe gerade die punkte ausgezählt
jetzt wahrscheinlich die ganze zeit
schon eingeblendet gesehen und jetzt
will ich sagen der verlierer kriegt eine
backpfeife und jetzt seid ihr fertig
seid ihr bereit dazu wo man die
kontrolle über merkels robert de niro
mein gott jetzt weiter alles was ihr vom
video oder das was jetzt hier vom video
hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
aus checken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnenten
können die auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]